what's going on guys this is Jay parks
filling in for Rob if you're enjoying
the content here on comics explained to
make sure you hit that lock button and
make sure that you subscribe so that you
can help Rob decide what direction he'll
take this channel in for the foreseeable
future okay so when Rob asked me to make
a video for the channel my first
instinct was to find a great trade
paperback and do a video on that one
story there are just two problems with
that approach a Rob has already done
almost all the trade paperbacks ever and
two if I do find a good story that Rob
has yet to cover then odds are I'd be
preventing him from telling that story
in the future and well I'd hate to cause
a riot and so the question becomes what
kind of countdown video shall I do now
way back in the ancient days of 2015 Rob
did a video called top five Batman facts
you didn't know now that seems like the
sort of video I can continue on with
without being burned at the stake so
today I'm gonna bring you guys the top
five Superman facts you didn't know and
if you'd like to see Rob finish out the
Holy Trinity with a top five Wonder
Woman video then let us know in the
comment section down below so a little
background on the Man of Steel to quote
me from the past since the 1930s the Big
Blue Boy Scout has been gracing comic
books TV shows and movies with his
presence Jerry Siegel and Joe Shuster
created the character in 1933 as a
villain bent on world domination that
was five years before his debut in DC
Comics in 1938 as the hero and with that
out of the way let's get the ball
rolling with number five
Superman's strange powers so when it
comes to the fans of this channel or
other channels like it it is not
impossible to actually find five facts
about Superman that you guys don't
already know about so there's some hyper
boil in these sorts of videos at least
in the title
however some of the powers Superman has
had in the past are so strange and
buried that I simply cannot leave them
out we're all familiar with Superman's
basic power set we all know that he can
fly is heat vision arctic breath
SuperSpeed x-ray vision and so on and so
forth at times though he's also had
telekinesis telepathy hypnotism and
super ventriloquism as opposed to
regular ventriloquist I guess but the
one that I find most interesting it came
in Superman number 45 in 1947 in this
issue Superman literally shape-shifted
he contorted his body into this pale
looking hairless alien and like many
weird powers it was never used or even
mentioned again oh and he can also
apparently launch tiny supermen out of
his hands so yeah that that was a thing
that happened moving on to the number
four spot once again we have something
that many of you guys probably already
know the original Superman couldn't fly
it's something that your average comic
reader or movie goer wouldn't know and
would likely be surprised to find out
but you guys are robbed core now when
Superman was first introduced in Action
Comics number one in 1939 his powers
were quite specific he could leap
one-eighth of a mouth his skin was near
bulletproof although a bursting shell
could still damage him and of course he
was super strong however it wasn't just
that he couldn't fly he also had no heat
or x-ray vision
no arctic breath and he never wants to
launched a single tiny sentient Superman
from his hand this would all change in
1941 when Fletcher studios found that it
was difficult to show Supes leaping from
one place to another when developing
their Superman animated shorts many of
Superman's actions had to be drawn and
they couldn't be rotoscoped
using techniques available at that time
flying was simply easier to animate
then leaping the power of flat would be
added to the comics soon after its
introduction in these cartoons that
brings us to number three Batman owns
Superman now this one is short but it's
also really fun within the Canon of DC
Comics Bruce Wayne is a billionaire I'm
sure that you're all just shocked by
that incredible revelation well you may
not be aware of though is that Bruce
Wayne bought the apartment building that
Clark and Lois live in and gave them
their apartment as a wedding gift
check out that mullet that is a grade-a
mullet
ten out of ten this is only mentioned
one time that I can find and it's in
Superman the wedding album a one-shot
issue where Clark Kent and Lois Lane get
married however rather than rock this
off because it's never referenced again
I prefer to think that Bruce Wayne is
just the type of guy that won't take a
little tiny thing like the fact that he
bought you your home and throw it up in
your face later not only that but Wayne
Industries owns the Daily Planet where
Superman works apparently he thought it
would be fun to run a newspaper that's
fair enough Bruce fair enough
now this is a bit off-topic but it
reminds me of that one scene in Batman
Begins where Bruce Wayne buys the hotel
he's dining at by like writing a check
and sticking it in the waiters pocket
that's that's not how you buy things
Bruce that's not how buying things works
and with that we move on to the number
two spot Superman versus the KKK let's
see if I can actually tell you guys
something that you don't know Superman
once took on the KKK in his radio show
so the story goes like this right after
World War Two the Klan underwent a
period of growth and became more brazen
and violent in their actions
a man named Stetson Kennedy joined as a
sort of spa along with a team of
undercover agents they all worked to get
as much information from this secretive
racist organization as possible his
theory was that if he could lift the
veil of secrecy surrounding the group
then he could rob it of my
of its power so Stetson approached the
Superman radio show and pitched them an
idea
Superman would go up against the Klan
and in the process of telling the story
they would expose all of the jargon and
secrets that Kennedy and his team had
uncovered this would serve to demystify
the Klan in the eyes of the public and
raise awareness they wrote up a huge
sixteen part story called clan of the
fiery cross and it's been said that this
exposure actually hurt their real-world
recruitment efforts this story is mostly
true aside from two details one
membership in the Klan had already been
on the decline since the 1930s and B
they didn't actually keep records of
their membership numbers so the claim
that it affected their recruitment
efforts can't be proven but still go
Superman good on you and with that we
find ourselves at the number one spot
the boy that tried to shoot Superman
George Reeves played the big blue cheese
in the 1950s television program
Adventures of Superman and Reeves used
to tell a story about a young fan that
pulled a pistol on him in an attempt to
test
Superman's invulnerability according to
the story
Reeves convinced the young boy that if
he shot Superman then the bullet might
bounce off him and hit some poor
innocent bystander and the child handed
over the weapon without further incident
the thing is there's actually no proof
of this happening it was made part of
the 2006 film Hollywood land but many
remained skeptical however true or not
it is a fact that reaps told this story
on numerous occasions and that's enough
for me to add it to the list so there
are five things about the Man of Steel
that maybe you didn't know if you guys
are new here to comics explained make
sure that you guys hit the subscribe
button to become part of the Rob core
and also you can check out my comic-book
channel in the description below
I talked about comic book history and
often try to relate it to philosophy I'm
Jay parks filling in for Rob and as he
always says I will
catch you later peace
[Music]